lors de l'entretien sans ses parents à
l'aide n'a pas eu à choisir la résidence
caltanissetta plaisait balaie du regard
d'amour tonnes non seulement chez papa
une semaine chez maman la solution
idéale pour ses parents qui désirent est
avant tout préserver leur petite fille
la voit prendre un mode de vie cadel 80
a très bien intégré pourquoi tu as le
partage comme ses deux chambres deux
garde-robe deux fois plus de jouer adele
a très rapidement apprécier les
avantages de la résidence alter 1 il
faut simplement bien s'organiser une
semaine ce ton papa et après équipiers
se fait manger le pire
chacun y trouve son compte sophie la
merde adhère au fil de sa semaine de
liberté pour se consacrer à son travail
s'occuper un peu d'elle elle est ainsi
plus à l écoute de sa fille quand elle à
votre ombre en semaine le fait qu'on
soit vive durer une semaine ou un laps
de temps ça nous permet aussi d'avoir
une vie sociale la semaine nous les en
fait non je dirais que ceux disponibles
pour elle tant d'années que la semaine
d'avant dont asus tendre ère où les
cours de faire le ménage de faire la
lessive toutes ces choses qui au
quotidien en fait nous nous prenne un
peu de temps par rapport un enfant quoi
un petit rituel ne pas oublier adèle pas
cette semaine chez son père mettre en
place la garde alternée
c'est parfois contraignant il faut
trouver en appartement pas trop loin de
l'école des copines
il faut aussi que les parents reaap
flamme à se parler pour l'équilibré de
l'enfant
si je devais voir adèle qu'une fois par
mois par exemple
bah on n'aura pas du tout les mêmes
relations en plus je pense que ça serait
pas mieux pour la mer parce que finira
par se retrouver dans dans une situation
où c'est maman qui dirige le week-end
avec papa on s'éclate et puis après on
retourne dans la routine donc c'est pas
bien gros plus pour le moment et à la
gym
j'ai passé quoi faire c'est maman qui
vous correspond une semaine entière pour
profiter pleinement de sa fin mais ils
sont encore rares trop rares comme
marque à pouvoir maintenir grâce à la
résidence alternée cette complicité avec
leurs enfants et les mères